well hi my name is Erica liderman I'm a
lawyer by training and an academic
associate at the center of genomics and
policy at McGill University and today
I'll be talking to you about
re-examining the ethical and regulatory
dimensions of gene editing in the wake
of the CRISPR baby sandal so to provide
you with an overview of what I plan to
cover today I'll start off by giving you
a brief overview of human germline
genome editing then we'll move on to
look at the international legal and
policy landscape I'll then present some
of the ethical failures in the aftermath
of the CRISPR babies scandal then I'll
move on to talk about well what's the
impact for Canada and I'll conclude by
considering well where do we go from
here and what is the feasibility of a
moratorium in this context so when we
talk about CRISPR caste 9 one of my
favorite analogies is to think of it as
a word processing tool so for example if
you're proofreading a document for typos
you can think of CRISPR as the tool that
enables you to search for the title then
once found cut or remove the typos and
then replace it with the correct word so
based on this analogy CRISPR can
identify the mutated gene remove it and
replace it with a healthy version of
that gene thus potentially treating or
preventing a slew of genetic diseases
now gene editing technologies have been
around for years so it's not new but
what CRISPR Cassadine does bring to the
table is that it offers a more
affordable or cheaper option it's easier
to use and it's purportedly more
accurate than other technologies such as
zinc fingers or talons so gene editing
can be used to cure patients so here we
can think of for example somatic cell
therapies it can be used to create
genetically healthy individuals so this
is where we can think about human
germline modifications so editing
embryos to ensure that they're born
healthy and then the third off the third
possibility is to enhance non-medical
physical and mental characteristics
however this is the more contentious
aspect
and there's general consensus that we
should not be using this technology for
enhancement purposes so I thought this
is a great slide to sort of compare and
contrast somatic gene editing versus
germline gene editing so when we talk
about somatic gene editing these are
edits that will target a specific type
of cell so for example blood cells that
means that any edits that are made will
be specific to that targeted cell and
any changes will remain with that given
individual so there's no chance of the
edits being passed on to future
generations also when we talk about
somatic cell therapies these have been
around for quite some time and so
they're generally in a highly regulated
context versus when we talk about
germline gene editing since the edits
are being made so early in the embryo
development process or to sperm and eggs
so the gametes it will any edits that
are made will impact all new cells so
that means as I've mentioned every cell
will be impacted by the edit and this
raises the concerns surrounding the
possibility that these changes will be
passed on to future generations and so
within this context they raise a slew of
new legal and societal considerations
moving forward so why is human germline
genome editing so controversial well
first we've got ethical and social
issues so under this category we'll find
the idea of the human hubris or the idea
of playing God and then there's also the
potential impact on societal perceptions
and attitudes towards individuals living
with disabilities there are also legal
and policy challenges so as I mentioned
on the previous slide there are new
considerations that arise with regards
to how do we regulate this technology
and then it also raises the question of
just because you can do something should
we and finally there is the meaning of
genetics in our culture so the idea of
genetic relatedness as the basis of
family relationships genetics as the
basis of health and disease the idea of
the heritage of humanity so the human
gene
not static but dynamic and evolves
naturally over time and then the concept
of genetic exceptionalism so that our
genes require special protections or
regulations now what are some
overarching ethical legal and social
issues that arise in the context of
germline modification so first we've got
safety and uncertainty of the technology
so this idea of crossing the germ line
barrier we then have the notion of risks
for future generations so the possible
irrevocable and unforeseen implications
down the line there's also the notion of
the preservation of human diversity and
individuality the respect for
individuals reproductive freedom so
individuals choice to access this
technology or use this technology or not
it also raises questions about
enhancement which ultimately can lead to
social justice issues such as new forms
of inequality discrimination and
societal conflict so under this the
umbrella of social justice we'll also
see the notion of equitable access to
the therapy so ensuring that those who
would really require or benefit most
from the technology have access and then
it's not just being used by those the
richest among us it also raises concerns
surrounding the need to protect the
welfare of children born from this
technology and the need for potential
long-term monitoring and follow-up to
ensure that these children are healthy
down the line and then the need for
meaningful and substantial public
engagement which is something that will
come up throughout my presentation so
this light provides you with a brief
overview of the CRISPR timeline
beginning with the publication of the
Chinese study using gene editing on non
viable human embryos to study or work
towards treating beta thalassemia so
this was published back in April of 2015
and it was the catalyst for
international debates surrounding the
use of CRISPR cast nine for Reproductive
purposes and for the treatment and
prevention of diseases
so following this in December of 2015
the first international summit on human
genome modification was held in
Washington and so what was concluded
from this meeting was really that it
would be irresponsible to move forward
with clinical applications of germline
editing and the fear being its
reproductive uses and what we can see
from this timeline is that essentially
it took three years before a scientist
actually went through with using
germline modification for Reproductive
purposes I'll come back to the that a
little bit later and so if we look at
the top of well the images and events
that occurred above the arrow we can see
an evolution in terms of the science so
in February of 2016 we had the first
license that was granted by the human
fertilization and embryology authority
in the UK to dr. Cathy Nikon to use gene
editing on healthy embryos with the
purpose of better understanding non
implantation and miscarriage similar
studies have also taken place in Sweden
we then had in August of 2017 the u.s.
study that was published by dr. Mutulu
passe where bias used gene editing to
correct a serious heritable heart
condition in healthy embryos that were
also destroyed within the 14-day window
and so what resulted from this study was
that we were beginning to generate and
address safety and efficacy concerns
surrounding germline editing I'll be it
in the research context so all the
studies up to this point have really
focused on research purposes of this
technology and then we had in November
of 2018
dr. huh announced the birth of the
CRISPR twin girls and so babies who had
been genetically a genetically modified
using germline modification and this was
announced two days before the second
international summit on human genome
modification and then if we look at the
events that took place at the bottom of
the error or in the lower half of the
screen what we can see is the
progression of statements and reports
that have come out surrounding a genome
editing more broadly so in February of
2017 we had the National Academies of
science engineering and medicine that
came out with their report then in July
to
18 we had the Nuffield Council on
bioethics and then in November of 2018
we had the statement that resulted from
the second international summit on human
genome modification and so essentially
what we see across these three reports
is an opening towards the possibility of
using germline modification in the
context of clinical trials provided that
stringent criteria are met and that
rigorous oversight is in place and the
last two bullets on on the timeline
allude to the creation of two
Commission's or committees to look at
this issue more broadly and I'll come
back to all of these points throughout
my presentation so now moving on to the
international legal and policy
challenges so at least 61 ethics reports
and statements by more than 50 countries
and organizations have been published
since 2015 an approximately 11% seem to
be open to the possibility of allowing
clinical applications of heritable
genome editing under certain conditions
so this map is a comparative legal and
policy analysis across a sample of 16
countries that was published in science
back in 2016 and what it does is it
provides a global snapshot of the
regulatory and policy approaches adopted
by these countries across six different
technologies and so I'm going to draw
your attention to the map in the top
left-hand corner so on human germline
genetic modification and what we see
here is essentially a patchwork of
regulatory landscape whereby some
countries adopt a more restrictive
approach so whether it be via criminal
ban and other countries adopting a much
more permissive approach with regards to
the regulation of germline modification
and something that we need to keep in
mind here is that what we're trying to
do with these regulations policies and
laws is really regulate the risks and
uncertainties of this novel disruptive
technology and so generally when we
consider legal and policy approaches
that are adopted to regulate human
germline modification there are three
that come up the first is a statutory
approach
this would include criminal law or
moratoria that are enshrined in law the
second is a regulatory approach so this
is the existence of oversight mechanisms
and the third is a policy approach so
this essentially entails guidelines and
so the 17 countries that will be on the
next slide actually stem from the
citation at the bottom of this slide so
it's a forthcoming book that's looking
at human a germline genome modification
on the right to science and it
essentially comparative study of
national laws and policies so what we
can see here is that most countries do
adopt a statutory approach with the
exception of China and whether it be
through criminal law civil law or a
moratorium that's enshrined in law as is
the case for Israel most of these
countries also adopt a regulatory
approach so they've got a national
regulatory authority that's mandated
with reviewing and providing approval
for the conduct of specific research and
this can be a licensing body an advisory
committee or a research Ethics Board and
finally we can see that fewer countries
adopt a policy approach but what I did
want to bring to your attention was that
if we look at China they're the only
country surveyed that adopt solely a
regulatory and policy approach so more
of a soft law approach to the regulation
of human germline modification and so
I'm gonna spend the next few slides and
talking about those reports that I
presented on the timeline and so the
first one is the National Academies of
science engineering and medicines report
on human genome editing that was
published in February of 2017 and I want
to draw your attention to two points
that were made so the first is with
regards to germline genome editing so
this report gives germline modification
a yellow light meaning that it would be
permissible for clinical research trials
to take place only for compelling
purposes of treating or preventing
serious diseases or disabilities and
only if there is a stringent oversight
system that's able to limit uses to
specific right
so basically you've got that stringent
oversight system in place and you've got
a specific set of criteria that must be
met then the other point I wanted to
draw your attention to was with regards
to human enhancement so the National
Academies essentially stated that we
should not proceed at this time with
human genome editing for purposes other
than treatment and prevention of disease
and disabilities and they encouraged
public discussion on somatic genome
editing for other uses so I had
mentioned that the National Academies
have put forward a list of criterion so
this is just a snapshot of a few
criteria that would need to be met the
list is much more exhaustive but these
criteria include for example the absence
of reasonable alternatives so using
human germline modification only as a
last resort when all else fails the need
for ongoing rigorous oversight during
clinical trials and the need for
comprehensive plans for long-term
multi-generational follow-up so as
mentioned this is just a snapshot of the
criteria that would need to be matched
if human germline modification were to
be allowed within a context of clinical
trials and so one point I wanted to
bring forward was this possible shift
from the notion of human germline
modification being irresponsible to
permissible that occurred between the
2015 first international summit on human
genome editing and the publication in
2017 of the National Academies of
Sciences and engineering and medicines
report so in the International summit
statement in 2015 they deemed that it
would be irresponsible to proceed with
any clinical use of germline editing
unless and until one the relevant safety
and efficacy issues have been resolved
and two there's broad societal consensus
about the appropriateness of the
proposed application so basically in
2015 what we see is that the moral line
is drawn between the approach or
technologies so it's a question of
somatic genome editing versus germline
modification and then when we shift over
to the 2017
report they state that clinical trials
using heritable germline genome editing
could one day be permitted for serious
conditions provided specific criteria
are met and stringent oversight is in
place so here we can see a shift in the
moral line towards the application or
the purpose of the technology so we're
talking about germline modification but
the distinction to be made is between is
it being used for therapeutic purposes
or for enhancement purposes the next
report I wanted to present was that of
the Nuffield Council on bioethics which
was published in July of 2018
and so as laid out in their recent
report heritable genome editing is not
unacceptable in itself that is it may
become morally acceptable in time but we
do need a responsible path forward so if
germline modification were to be
permitted it should be strictly
regulated by the human fertilization and
embryology Authority for example in the
UK it should be introduced only in the
context of a clinical study with
monitoring of the long term effects on
individuals and groups so within a well
controlled context and it should be
licensed on a case-by-case basis
so not a free-for-all and a further
recommendation that's put forward is the
need to establish an independent body in
the UK to promote broad and inclusive
societal debate on heritable genome
editing interventions and related
scientific and medical developments and
the final statement I'm going to present
is that stemming from the second
international summit on human genome
editing that came out in November of
2018 so what we see here is that with
regards to basic and preclinical
research the statement suggests that
this should be permitted as it will
enable a better understanding and design
of the techniques the statement also
proposes a translational pathway forward
that will require adhering to widely
accepted standards for clinical research
and establishing standards for
preclinical evidence and accuracy so
this need for a rigorous and responsible
path forward the
maintain that it would be irresponsible
to use human germline modification in
the context of reproductive purposes or
clinical purposes and they call for this
for this need for an ongoing
international forum and I need to foster
broad public dialogue so now what I
wanted to present in the next few slides
are really some ethical shortcomings or
failures that arose in the aftermath of
the CRISPR baby scandal so as mentioned
earlier on and the announcement of the
birth of genetically modified twin girls
in China was done a couple days before
the second international summit in Hong
Kong and it was announced via a YouTube
video and so essentially what happened
was that this researcher dr. Huff had
used germline modification on the
embryos to render them HIV resistant so
modified the ccr5 gene so to render them
resistant to a specific strain of HIV in
this context it was a healthy mother and
an HIV father and it was presented as a
clinical trial so what I want to do now
is demonstrate how facts from the CRISPR
babies situation or scandal actually map
onto these long-standing and
well-established principles of ethical
clinical research if we were to consider
the issue of social or scientific value
so there was a lack of compliance with
Chinese regulations and a violation of
international consensus to hold off on
clinical applications of human germline
gene editing in terms of scientific
validity there was a lack of
transparency in dr. ho's work and it was
not published or peer-reviewed and the
same goes for prior animal studies that
he had conducted with regards to fair
subject selection it was alleged there
was alleged undue inducement of parents
to participate in the clinical trial as
they were promised up to $42,000 to
cover any costs that are related with
medical treatment or medical care in
terms of the favorable risk benefit
ratio well the choice of gene is not met
we've justified so it's not a clear
life-threatening disease or condition
and approved methods of prevention
already exist such as sperm washing so
in this context there was no rationale
or medical rationale to use germline
modification since other options were
readily available in terms of
independent review there was a lack of
valid ethics approval from an
institutional review board and doctor
has institution allegedly was unaware of
the clinical trials taking place in
terms of informed consent there was a
lack of a valid and acceptable informed
consent form so the consent form was
long over 23 pages it was also written
in a lot of scientific jargon so not
easily accessible or or written in lay
terms for the parents to understand and
there was misinformation that was
presented to the parents so this was
presented as an AIDS vaccine trial
likely to benefit their children which
was not in fact the case and finally if
we think about respect for potential and
enrolled subjects doctor who failed to
disclose his conflicts of interest to
participants in the trial and the final
point I wanted to raise here was that
doctor who had also informed several
peers about his plans yet none
sufficiently intervened to discourage
him from following through so the
question of where does the
responsibility lie comes up in this
context now stemming from the CRISPR
baby scandal there are four common
themes that will come up as an ethical
critique so the first is the specter of
eugenics so this is common regarding any
genetic innovations and it's a reminder
of the need to discuss proposed genetic
interventions prospectively or ahead of
time so what's our target what's our
goal where do we draw the line what
would be permissible and this then ties
into the second theme that of risks to
future children and parental freedoms so
there were the high risks in this study
or in this clinical trial were not
justified in the context as reproductive
autonomy and desires of biological
Parenthood took precedence over the
consideration of possible how
wrists to the children a third theme is
the failure of professional
self-regulation which will assume a lack
of professional codes of conduct however
this is a false assumption as it was not
the absence of self regulatory
mechanisms but of the implementation of
China's existing guidelines and
regulations that were not adhered to in
this context and the final theme is that
at the chilling effect this is the fear
that legitimate progress will be stifled
according to Francis Collins should such
epic scientific misadventures precede a
technology with enormous promise for
prevention and treatment of disease will
be overshadowed by justifiable public
outrage fear and disgust
now another ethical concern that arose
in this context was the possibility that
the CRISPR twins might have had their
brains inadvertently enhanced so new
research shows that the deletion of the
ccr5 gene makes my smarter and improves
human brain recovery after stroke which
could be linked to greater success in
school so a form of cognitive
enhancement now the question that comes
up here is what will the effects be on
the girls cognition and this is
something that is impossible to predict
at this time a recent article that had
been published considering this question
of well is enhancement the price of
prevention states that science
policymakers will need to think more
carefully about what prevention might
mean in the gene editing context and
develop research governance that can
anticipate and address the human
enhancement concerns it will raise so if
the scope of acceptable clinical
research is expanded to include
preventive strengthening interventions
the door is open to protocols that raise
enhancement concerns so balancing the
health gains of prevention against the
social cost of enhancement will require
scientific reflection as well as social
wisdom now how could we possibly
mitigate such ethical breaches so the
first would be to put an emphasis on
ethical and responsible research norms
and Trust fees a second would be
to adopt appropriate enforcement and
oversight mechanisms a third would be to
develop a common groundwork so shared
values and principles both
internationally and try to harmonize
across cultures and countries there's
also the need to align with local
preferences and long-standing ethical
principles and practices and finally the
idea of a research ethics consultation
system and process that's geared towards
human participants in the context of
cutting-edge clinical research and so in
this context it's important not just to
seek harmonization of ethical policies
worldwide but also to seriously consider
how countries like China which are
aggressively seeking to become leaders
in cutting-edge and often controversial
fields can develop local research ethics
frameworks that align with both local
preferences as well as long-standing and
well-established ethical principles and
practices so what are some of the steps
that have been taken by China following
the scandal so China has aimed to
further strengthen their ethics
governance by creating a national
medical ethics committee that would be
tasked with approving all clinical
trials involving high-risk biomedical
technology China has also put forward
new draft regulations that restrict the
use of human genome editing which is
considered to be high risk and would
require the approval by Chinese
authorities and ethics committees prior
to being permitted to proceed to
clinical trials so these regulations
call for greater oversight and
accountability on the part of health
institutions regarding the clinical
trials taking place within their
institutions and the draft regulations
can also result in penalties for the
researchers whether it be fines lifetime
bans criminal investigations or the
relocation of licenses back in March of
2019 18 scientists and ethicists from
seven countries put forward a call to
adopt a moratorium on heritable genome
editing and so they proposed a five year
moratorium on clinical applications of
germline
vacation they state that by global
moratorium they don't mean a permanent
ban but rather they call for the
establishment of an international
framework in which nations while
retaining the right to make their own
decisions voluntarily commit to not
approve any use of clinical germline
editing unless certain conditions are
met
now a binding global moratorium would
bring with it concerns as to its
feasibility and its ability to be
operationalized as well as it might even
stifle necessary public debate so the
questions that arise here have to do
with well what a moratorium really be
effective how would we actually
implement and enforce it and most
countries already criminally prohibit
germline modifications for clinical
purposes so what does a moratorium
actually add then one month later a
letter signed by more than 60 American
scientists CEOs and bioethicists was
sent to the secretary of the US
Department of Health and Human Services
calling for a binding global moratorium
limiting clinical testing of germline
gene editing in humans and the need for
effective and easily accessible
mechanisms for reporting potential
violations I do want to point out that
although a good portion of the letter
alludes to this need for a global
moratorium on germline editing the
latter half of the letter is more of a
plea to continue to support an advanced
somatic gene therapies so any non
germline correction furthermore we've
got the World Health Organization expert
Advisory Committee on developing global
standards for governance and oversight
of human gene editing that was
established in December of 2018 and so
their first step was really a call for a
global registry of studies on human
genome editing and as we can see by the
headline at the bottom of this slide the
World Health Organization expert
advisory committee has approved the
first phase of a new global registry so
it has launched so we see forward
movement and ultimately the goal of the
w-h-o committee is to work towards a
strong
hence of global governance framework for
responsible stewardship of human genome
editing in a similar line we also have
the newly established International
Commission on clinical use of heritable
human genome editing which was
established in May of 2019 and the focus
of this commission however is a bit more
towards the clinical applications of
human germline genome editing and to
further inform a potential translational
path towards the clinic now as we move
on to consider well what is the impact
of all of this for Canada more
specifically well in Canada germline
modification and somatic gene editing
are overseen or fall under the purview
of the assisted Human Reproduction Act
which is a piece of criminal legislation
as well as under the Tri council policy
statement or TCPS - which essentially
governs research involving humans to
ensure that it's being conducted in an
ethical manner so germline modification
is prohibited under Article v 1f of
these two human reproduction acts which
states that no person shall knowingly
alter the genome of a cell of a human
being or in vitro embryo such as the
alteration is capable of being
transmitted to descendants and anyone
found guilty of this is liable of a fine
up to $500,000 imprisonment up to ten
years or both so quite draconian
sanctions if you if you go against this
law so in the wake of the CRISPR babies
well what does this mean for science in
Canada so Canada's criminal prohibition
of basic research using human germline
modification is unnecessarily
restrictive so we need a renewed
Canadian conversation a potential
example of this or way forward would be
a democratic engagement process of
public consultation that could
potentially be led by Health Canada
there's also a need to reorient our
models of governance of emerging bio
technologies to shift away from criminal
law towards regulations perhaps there's
also a need to strengthen scientific
literacy about humans
research and reproductive medicine to
enable ongoing review of Canadian laws
than policies and there's a need for an
independent review body that's charged
with guiding ongoing reforms to the
assisted Human Reproduction Act and the
TCPS - in light of emergent technologies
and one point that I wanted to make was
the criminal prohibition on human
germline modification in Canada is both
in a research context so basic research
could not be done as well as in a
clinical context and so this is where
our major concern is the conflation of
those two contexts under in criminal law
and so ultimately an inclusive approach
to policymaking is needed that
recognizes a variety of opinions and
voices and this can be seen through the
consensus statement so this resulted
from a series of workshops on prohibited
research activities that aimed at
developing recommendations for reform so
this was led by our Center as well as
collaborators across Canada and
essentially what we see stemming from
this consensus statement is the right of
Canadians to benefit from the
advancement of science
the need to avoid criminal bans on
research I need for proportional policy
making and then the need to distinguish
between research and clinical contexts
with regards to germline modification
and other prohibited activities under
the assisted Human Reproduction Act
following the consensus statement a
series of consultations with
stakeholders and end-users were held
which resulted in this recently
published paper that proposes pragmatic
reforms in support of research so what
we propose is a tailored regulatory
carve out for in-vitro research for
currently prohibited activities under
the assisted Human Reproduction Act and
for the exercise of ministerial
discretion for access by Canadians to
experimental in vivo interventions that
are currently prohibited and all of this
would be overseen by a new national
agency similar to the human
fertilization embryology Authority in
the UK or one that's modeled on a blend
of the Canadian stem-cell oversight
committee and what was the assisted
human record
in Canada another point that we need to
consider as we saw in the statements I
presented earlier on it seems this
notion of serious appears in terms of
considerations of what would be
permissible applications of human
germline modification so generally we
seem to see that it would be permissible
for the treatment or prevention of
serious genetic disorders however
nowhere has this notion of serious been
classified or defined making its
application rather vague so this is
something we'll need to consider moving
forward how do we define it
do we need to define it and what would
criteria be that would help us better
understand and apply it so now where do
we go from here well if we consider
public attitudes it appears to be the
application rather than the technology
itself that is the critical issue for
the public the nature of support for
gene editing is complex and determined
by the application the type of style and
also individual differences and what
they've also found is that there seems
to be significantly higher support
amongst males younger people and those
reporting lower religiosity more
knowledge and stronger trust in science
the next point is as I had alluded to
earlier on is the right to enjoy the
benefits of science and it's
applications so this was first
recognized in the Universal Declaration
of Human Rights back in 1948 under
Article 27 1 which states that everyone
has the right to freely participates and
to share in scientific advancements and
its benefits this right was later
enshrined in article 15 B of the
International Covenant on economic
social and cultural rights in 1966 and
essentially it can be seen as a means
through which scientific advances having
a positive impacts on human health can
be promoted and shared for the benefit
of all it's also right that has remained
largely dormant and its scope and
normative content poorly elaborated
within the literature and it's only
really in the last decade that we're
seeing a reawakening of this right
I wanted to include this quote by Eric
yangste that states the goal is such a
novel human rights approach is to
reorient our conversation from policing
science to governing society and would
shift our focus from avoiding risks to
protecting opportunities so this idea of
trying to apply a human rights approach
to the idea of human germline editing
and ultimately this would foster
advancements in our ability to treat and
prevent disease while remaining mindful
of the need to establish anticipatory
governance that provides the necessary
flexibility to frame the preventive or
therapeutic applications but also adapt
to potentially legitimate off-label ones
a next point to consider are the rights
of future generations so the Oviedo
convention explicitly prohibited
modification of the human genome it
maintained that preventive diagnostic or
therapeutic purposes are recognized as
legitimate only if their aim is not to
introduce any modification in the genome
of any descendants and it also
recognizes that scientific progress
should be used for the benefit of
present and future generations this
notion of protecting future generations
and their interests was further
enshrined in the 1997 declaration on the
responsibilities of the present
generation towards future generations
and in the 2005 Universal Declaration on
bioethics and human rights this notion
of the rights of future generations have
also been incorporated into national
documents such as the constitution of
Japan and the Nuffield Council on
bioethics latest report so in line with
the rights of future generations is also
this notion of intergenerational
monitoring so as mentioned in the
Nuffield Council on bioethics 2018
reports they raise the idea of
transgenerational ISM and questions
surrounding the responsibilities and
obligations to both the next generation
and future generations
there's also Quebec Commission on ethics
and science and technologies 2019
reports that proposes adopting a
precautionary approach so to ensure that
appropriate measures
and mechanisms are in place specifically
considering potential irrevocable and
unforeseen consequences of human
germline modification on future
generations some examples could be
adopting stringent scientific standards
or to limit potential clinical
applications to very serious high
penetrance diseases so this idea using
it as a last resort or the development
of an electronic register for
longitudinal medical monitoring now
continuing on this notion although
typical in research on new reproductive
technologies long term follow-up has
always been limited to the parents and
their direct descendants and it provides
little guidance on how to address the
ethical participation of multiple
generations so long-term follow-up
monitoring would be not just of
participants in the original trial but
also their children and even
grandchildren who are not part of the
original consent process and so this
ultimately raises concerns about consent
as a patient can provide consent whereas
the future child cannot there's also the
concern of rogue scientists and how do
we prevent this from happening in the
future and so one proposition by Alta
Charo was that an ultra alternative
approach is to take advantage of the
ecosystem of regulatory actors and
develop a roadmap for responsible
translational research such guidance
would include stringent criteria for use
of germline editing and standards for
determining whether these criteria have
been met and this would all be embedded
within larger political structures that
offer vehicles for public input so the
alternative approach suggests a sort of
broader more inclusive approach to to
managing rogue scientists now as I
mentioned earlier on Doctor Who had
informed several peers about his plans
yet none sufficiently intervened to
discourage him from following through
most scientists simply don't recognize
an obligation to speak up and so some
reasons for this violence could be
uncertainty over dr. his intentions or a
reassurance that he had been dissuaded
there's also the possibility and that
they felt a sense of obligation to
preserve
inshallah T and the absence of a global
oversight body so ultimately the science
is a symptom of a broader scientific
cultural crisis a growing divide between
the values upheld by the scientific
community and the mission of science
itself so we need to be able to reflect
on how our research fits into society
ultimately a fundamental goal of the
scientific endeavor is to advance
society through knowledge and innovation
the dominant values ingrained and
scientists enter on the virtues of
independence ambition and objectivity
however in decisions about how and
whether this technology should be used
we will require and expand instead of
scientific virtues including compassion
to ensure its applications are designed
to be just humility to ensure its risks
are heated and altruism to ensure its
benefits are equitably distributed and
so finally this notion of open science
which aims to create new knowledge
through global collaborations involving
thousands of people from across the
world and from all walks of life so the
goal being really to engage with
citizens of active participants and
facilitate open and accessible research
ultimately a well-informed consulted and
involved audience is more likely to
support research and scientific progress
and so this need to make citizens active
participants in scientific development
was proposed over 21 years ago in the
Vito convention under article 28 so and
now to conclude with considerations with
raghava moratorium so one it could be
argued that an arbitrary moratorium does
not further or foster the best interests
or health of children or respect their
right to access the advancements of
science in short the reason calls the
global moratoria are troubling in that
they may create an illusion of control
or of oversight of rogue science they
could silence what should be an ongoing
and vigorous international debate
surrounding a responsible translational
passed forward and they would be
paradoxical as legal prohibitions
surrounding human germline editing
already exist and they would unwittingly
reinforce the
it's a much-needed examination of the
actual and future interest of children
so a better and more realistic route may
be to focus efforts on enforcing current
laws regulations and guidelines while
fostering public dialog through
participative approaches and ongoing
enforcement by national authorities may
be a more efficient use of time and
resources in our goal of establishing a
robust and ethically responsible
framework moving forward and so I want
to end with this slide which is the
cover of Time magazine I believe in
January 2019 which focuses on the future
of babies and so it looks at gene
editing and so the idea is the CRISPR
baby controversy the start of a
terrifying new chapter in gene editing
it considers uterus transplants so the
first successful uterus transplant from
deceased donor leads to a healthy baby
which is actually the baby on the cover
and finally three biological parents or
mitochondrial replacement therapy and
the possibility that reports of these
babies are multiplying so I believe at
this point at least ten babies have been
born using mitochondrial replacement
therapy however the UK is the only
country to have legally permitted use of
this technology but none of the babies
that have been born have actually been
born in the UK so this raises two main
points that I feel we need to consider
moving forward one is where to draw the
line with enhancement or where do we
draw lines in the sand at all in this
context and two it raises concerns or
raises future concerns and
considerations beyond gene editing the
idea of re-engineering and a need to
reframe assisted reproductive
technologies as a whole so on that note
I want to thank you for your attention